I'm not really sure what to expect to be
honest I mean I don't know what we're
gonna get is it like stale other bite
marks in it is it like I'm good yeah I
have no idea
I'm so confused I'm I don't know how to
feel about this so there's this app
called too good to go it's basically
like a food delivery app for your phone
except it's for leftover food from
restaurants at the end of the day and
you gotta go pick it out it shows you
like a list of restaurants attorney you
and the prices are around 150 to 3000 by
these two guys in Denmark in 2015 Chris
Wilson and Jamie crummy it was supposed
to be a way for restaurants get rid of
leftover food at the end of the day
probably all about hiring insiders who
really lazy less food waste is a nasty
waste it's also a stretch I think it's a
rescue 1,500 meals and we've decided to
use it as a real mission education I'm
not just a quick
so we're going to try out four
restaurants a day and see what it's like
I'm not really sure what to expect if I
was in college I'd be probably pretty
psyched about it
I mean I'm so pretty excited about it
I think this is tuna or ham not really
sure it's like bacon I can't believe how
good that is I think and I think it was
really really easy to get you walked up
just said like here's the app and then
they gave us a bunch of stuff yeah once
again it's great it's good as the
founders of the app to lists like is
what he's got in the trash then in my
eating trash I don't know how to feel
about this I guess it's easy but not as
easy as having it delivered but then I
do like save unlike you know not having
to pay for the deliveries it gets me out
walking I guess you know it's half price
and it's good you know what would I ever
use the app again it's sort of weird you
have to go to the restaurant P and I
also feel sort of conflicted about the
fact that the foods not being donated
feel like that would be like the ideal
thing to do the two guys behind the app
seem to have a pretty good idea of what
they want to see in the world with it
would you ever use it again um if I
wanted to like get food I would probably
have it delivered cheap food lazy food